yeah welcome to this video and don't be
shocked by the ratings it's a challenge
blitz game it's not a regular
five-minute auto protein game I've been
challenged here to two games um by a
spectator of the channel so on chats go
ahead here from 25 minute games that are
not in this in this auto pairing but in
the challenging system okay I'm an Enzo
Union and bit of on-site life I actually
confused the most of it so on that is
not what I wanted to have initially but
it's not them it's not the terrible
position okay yeah well I need to put
some pawns in the center it's a myth
anyway that the news Oh indian or queens
in you know those openings that they aim
to control the center by pieces i mean
at the end you need to put bones there
is mostly just a delay there are very
few lines and the names of are all
similar openings where you really don't
put anything in the center but some
mostly just a matter of when do you put
it in the center okay before played
young it's not nice I wanted to take
play d5 get an isolated Queens pawn
position but he will probably answer
with c5 and then I really don't damn I
really lack space
will be 96 it's not very comfortable
don't like the position rush
I'm not sure that I'm even threatened
something now maybe I threatened to take
on on before I on deform sorry on d
phone takes takes Knight takes bishop h7
it's not it's not a porn on age seven so
yeah maybe I lost I lost too much time
with age 67 I didn't want to eat okay so
let's take it I'm glad to have a poem
bribe it's not clear at all he can maybe
play Knight be five but the Sun wasn't
what I had in mind might be five with
the idea to go to d6 Tom would have been
bit ugly ok now I probably need to drop
back at least I want a pawn
hmm yeah that's still not not a very
convenient position you can play maybe
c5 at some some point like here it's not
um not great all this oh if I take ya
maybe I know I cannot even play this I
thought d5 but he just takes it eat
tasty 626 is not on the page seven
otherwise d5 would be okay hmm this is
ugly
maybe a five or something i don't know
if i take it you and your captures with
the poem okay i need to play move frets
it's not nice to take we have some some
decent compensation retakes with the
point maybe if it takes with the pawn I
can play Queen 85 intending yeah at
least what these six now t6e just takes
what a shame yeah I hope that Bishop a
60 symbols I'd also doesn't really it
doesn't really help I played e5 I could
do that 96 rookie seven talk about an
ugly position
yeah that really sucks everything's
positioned well not how it is supposed
to be yeah can prob do i need to move it
somewhere 95 but i can maybe take and
play Bishop these things but i need to
need to play Wickham no use yeah I know
I know but what can I do
36 is also not possible yeah I probably
need to give up the exchange at least I
have a square on e4 hopefully yeah okay
if you take this as nothing I can do
about it but I have night no night night
f5 is actually a good turkey push up a
795 the Queen doesn't have asked where
to go yeah come on Boyd f5 and I to you
for this this looks like some some
decent activity yeah Queen can go to a 6
but what what can I do
doesn't build them how to get get more
counter delay maybe use the h-bond each
four or something yeah I will play rook
group to see eight at some point
yeah well I'm a ticking f form and maybe
know each form assume this on well it's
not objectively great so maybe I can
stay up some trouble so check and come
on a five yeah I hope that that I can
take b5 now probably die cannot takes
Queen f3 Queen f1 years unbelievable
okay so this is neither three coming
another three is at least a threat wow I
sit spin it spin I don't believe it ah
time morning I can take no here rupee to
coming
night f2 is a threat check check check
check check check check check check
check check mate who this was wow I
really escaped he put up a great fight
look at the writing difference this was
a ooh very very tight game i probably
lost at some point but ok it's a blitz
game but what can you do yeah thanks for
watching and guess so we'll have a
rematch coming up